[Music]
hi everybody I'm drew Carey I'm here in
Brentwood California outside of a
perfectly legal pharmacy Brentwood
sounds familiar to you it's right
outside of Los Angeles it's where OJ's
to live it's a really rich area and in
this pharmacy like any farmers in the
United States you can get pills for
whatever ails you over-the-counter
prescription you can get aspirin
eyedrops ear drops creams also if you're
into if you need a little pick-me-up you
can go across the street to Starbucks
and get a cup of coffee a strong cup of
coffee not so strong cup of coffee
whatever you want you can just decide
your own dose right next to that is a
bar restaurant you can get cocktails
beer wine alcohol there's another door
made like liquor store right down the
block
so while within walking distance here in
this really rich area of California you
can get anything you want to bring it up
or down or in between but there's one
thing they sell here in California
that's legal that the federal government
doesn't want you to have so here I am in
front of the pharmacy in West Hollywood
it's on Santa Monica Boulevard right by
Santa Monica and Fairfax really busy
street busy intersection is one of over
a hundred places Los Angeles where if
you have a note from your doctor you can
get rare flowers fine herbs or organic
medicine in other words medical
marijuana smell that smell
to smell the freedom inside I found a
clean well-lit place to legally buy
cannabis so here I am in the backroom of
the pharmacy the medical marijuana
dispensary and she could see it's like a
deli I mean they have a you know
marijuana cooking the food ice cream
drinks like lemonade strawberry lemonade
and their cookies so it's pretty cool so
I'll really out in the open and we can
just see you exactly what you're getting
and pay for it with a credit card I
tried to get a drink here but they don't
have a liquor license well we come a
long way haven't we you know back in the
30s when the government was trying to
stomp out marijuana they made a movie
called reefer madness which is kind of
like a comedy cult classic now where
they showed marijuana smokers is
derelict to society
we couldn't even smoke marijuana right
[Music]
and still today the federal government
has marijuana and the same
classification as heroin now you think
if you take these drugs you're gonna end
up on Skid Row homeless no hope no
control over your life but with
marijuana it's just not true
take steps share who looks like the
successful corporate woman that she is
Stef was an event planner in San Diego
but an injury changed her life and her
career not only is Stef of medical
marijuana user but she started an
organization to help others get safe and
reliable medical cannabis in 2000 I had
a severe neck injury and left me with
the condition called torticollis which
basically means all of the muscles in my
neck are in constant spasm and that
actually causes my skull to collapse on
itself and causes my jaw to also
collapse about a year-and-a-half into
that injury my kidneys started failing
because of side-effects of ibuprofen and
pain medication and one day I went to
see my doctor to discuss this this new
problem and he asked me if I smoked pot
and I told him I didn't and he asked me
if I knew where to get some and I asked
him if I was his youngest patient
because I thought that he was trying to
get me to score pot for him I had no
idea what he was talking about so he
assured me that that was not the case
but that he had two patients that were
using cannabis as an adjunct therapy
with their other medications and they
were able to cut back the amount of
ibuprofen and painkillers that they were
taking and so he suggested that if I
could find some that I should try it at
the time he said I was about six months
away from dialysis
across town we met bill ley he runs a
very successful printing business tell
you what he's not he's not some
strung-out doper living on Skid Row
like they'd make you think he would be
because he's his marijuana I'm a hawk I
mean I'm a right wing I volunteered to
go to Vietnam I joined the service I've
always been a Republican I'm very for
law and order right and wrong right to
have my guns you know you want my gun
you better take it off my dead body
period no questions medical marijuana in
my particular case for taking it is for
a variety of reasons Marfan's is just a
genetic problem that brought on the
other symptoms but I have an s-shaped
spine and a curvature of the spine that
was everyone always thought was brought
on by the quick growth spurt but it
seems to be inherent with with that and
I actually didn't know I had Marfan's
until I had the Triple A surgery and the
medical marijuana or medical cannabis
has helped alleviate the pressure in my
back I mean I had tremendous pressure on
my back sometimes I'll wake up in the
middle of the night I can't even sleep
in my arms hurt and it's all pain that's
stemming from here going on to have but
I'm able to go in and I'll take my pipe
and I'll take a puffer to relax a little
bit and I'll be able to go back and go
to sleep and come to work the amount
that I needed was was much greater than
what I was finding and so people started
giving me the names of their dealers the
last straw for me was one day I was
sitting in
Walgreens parking lot waiting for a
dealer to come and meet me and he was
late about two hours had gone by and I
was just sitting in this parking lot
watching people go in and out going in
and getting their prescriptions and
leaving you know leaving with without
looking over their back without worrying
about what was going to happen to them
after they left
and finally this dealer showed up two
and a half hours late and he told me he
thought I was a cop and he wouldn't sell
the marijuana to me and so I found
myself in this Walgreens parking lot
bawling my eyes out to the skater kid
you know and I just knew I couldn't live
like that and friends of mine had told
me about medical cannabis dispensaries
in the Bay Area and so I went to visit
and actually came back to San Diego
closed down my business and moved up to
the Bay Area to be closer to the
dispensaries about two months into their
getting settled there was a DEA raid on
one of the dispensaries in San Francisco
I was terrified and frustrated that I
had changed my entire life to be near
this medication and that that access to
be shut off as well
medical marijuana has been legal in
California since prop 215 passed in 1996
by a large margin but the federal
government doesn't agree with the
citizens of California and uses the
Controlled Substances Act to continue to
conduct raids on the marijuana
dispensaries with the support of local
police now even though the reason
foundation is a very serious scholarly
kind of a group and I'm not exactly some
left-wing nut the DEA and the LAPD
refused our request for interviews but I
did get to sit down with Steve Whitmore
the sheriff's department spokesman for
Los Angeles County well the Sheriff's
Department in general under the
direction of sheriff Baca treats medical
marijuana dispensaries low on the
priority scale of law enforcement in the
areas in which we have jurisdiction in
the areas that we patrol for example
where there are medical marijuana
dispensaries what we do is that we
monitor the outside we make sure we
monitor
what's going on and make sure that
nothing illegal is taking place and
whenever it does we obviously move in
and do what's appropriate my first
experience with medical marijuana came
when I was in the service in Vietnam and
I found that to be something that I that
was comfortable for me because I don't
drink alcohol and it gave me a sense of
calmness and certainly if you've been in
combat a sense of calmness is a nice
place to be so I found that very
comforting when I first heard of it I
was afraid of it but then I once I tried
it and found that it wasn't a terrible
thing it was a good thing then I
proceeded to use it and have used it
since and so I use actually a t-shirt
which is basically use alcohol to
extract the medical compounds out of the
plant it's a very common way to make
medicines from whole plant substances so
if you go to your local herbal store or
Whole Foods you'd probably find an
echinacea tincture or a Saint John's
wort tincture it's the same same process
but with cannabis cannabis has a very
distinct purpose and has a very positive
purpose if it's used correctly the
silliness of charging in and breaking
doors down and grabbing things I think
they just tried to bankrupt the
pharmacies put them out of business come
in and take their money and take their
product and then see if they can regroup
and financially continue and that's not
the right thing to do you don't they
don't do that to other places if medical
marijuana was decriminalized nationally
if the DEA stood down their plate would
be full with other drugs I mean just the
abuse of prescription drugs I don't
think well it's a good question
it's it's an excellent question I can't
answer that I'm not a member of the
federal government however if I was
sitting across from our current
president I would certainly encourage
him to do so so I think it's clear by
now that the federal government needs to
reclassify marijuana people that need it
should be able to get it safely and
easily and if that bothers you that
really makes you nervous that people are
out there using marijuana to to ease
their pain here's what you do drive down
any old gas station in America like this
one
go inside buy yourself a nice cold brew
pop the top they really take the edge
off for the reason foundation
I'm drew Carey
[Music]